but you guys are fun you know a lot of
crowds very sensitive now people are
getting sensitive my buddy he's a vegan
holy I'm walking on eggshells around him
he really hates that he's a great guy I
love him to death but going out to eat
with's a nightmare every time we go out
to eat he's got to have the impossible
Burger know about this thing looks like
meat tastes like meat feels like meat
but it's not meat weird you hate
something but you want something just
like it it's kind of like a lesbian with
a strap
on you hate dick but it looks like a
dick feels like a dick I Can't Believe
It's Not
dick we got the lesbian here
tonight hey all right I think that was a
guy I feel like lesbians are
underrepresented I travel the country
doing comedy I see gay bars everywhere
they always have funny names like the
manhole or the back door you know
where's all the fun lesbian bars where's
like kits with a
z clits be a perfect name for a lesbian
bar cuz no guy could find
it and you know what we'll put her right
in the
hood